هذه قصة غامضة ومثيرة للقلق للغاية تم
الإبلاغ عنها لأول مرة من قبل
صحيفة الرياضة الفرنسية اليومية mckeep والتي
تثير تساؤلات جدية
حول اللاعب المحتمل على عنف اللاعب داخل
فريق كرة القدم للسيدات
PSG أكد النادي أن أميناتا دييلو البالغة من العمر 26 عامًا
قد تم القبض عليها في منزلها خارج
باريس في وقت مبكر من يوم الأربعاء فيما يتعلق
بالاعتداء الأسبوع الماضي على زميلة في الفريق ،
حددت عدة تقارير أن زميلتها في الفريق
هي كيرا
حمراوي وفقًا لتوضيح الجدول الزمني
للقصة ، حيث كانت كيرا حمراوي هذه تم نقلها
إلى المنزل بواسطة ديالو بعد عشاء الفريق
يوم الخميس عندما كانت  تم سحبها
من السيارة من قبل مهاجمين ملثمين
ثم قاموا بضربها بقضيب حديدي مع التركيز
على ساقيها واستشهدوا بمصدر
يقول إنه من الغريب أنه لم يتم سرقة أي شيء
أثناء الهجوم وأن ديالو لم
يتعرض للضرب
في هذه المرحلة لا نعرف ما هي
المعلومات وما الدليل
تعمل الشرطة على تحديد ما إذا كان Diallo
متورطًا بالفعل في هذا الأمر ، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك ، فكيف ولكن من
المستحيل عدم ملاحظة أنهم يلعبون
نفس المركز بالنسبة للنادي
والبلد وعندما يتم إقصاء الحمراوي
لأي سبب من الأسباب ، فهذا يعني المزيد من
الفرص للشابة ديالو كما
كان الحال في مباراة الثلاثاء ضد
ريال مدريد حمراوي وهي حاليًا في
ذروة قوتها الكروية التي فازت
بدوري الأبطال الموسم الماضي.  هي
لاعبة خط الوسط الأساسية في باريس سان جيرمان وخبيرة
في المنتخب الفرنسي ،
وعندما أبعدتها الإصابة عن
تصفيات كأس العالم للسيدات الشهر الماضي ،
تم استدعاء ديالو من الفريق للمساعدة في
ملء هذا المكان
في بيان باريس سان جيرمان يقول إنهم اتخذوا
كل ما يلزم.  الإجراءات منذ الاعتداء
لحماية لاعبيها تسعى أيضا
للحصول على تعليق من ديالو من الحمراوي
ومن النيابة العامة
سيرو فانييه سي إن باريس.